our 13 soldiers and civilians have died
in eastern Ukraine the deadliest surge
of violence since the government and
pro-russian insurgents struck a
ceasefire deal earlier on we asked a
Harlan Ullman a senior adviser at the
Brent Scowcroft center on international
security in Washington if the ceasefire
violations were a surprise this was to
be expected the truth has been very
tenuous there's still going to be a lot
of conflict between the separatists and
Kiev and what we have to do is to be
able to deal with these incidents as
they arrive and try to contain them and
I hope that the peacekeeping force and
the observers were there will be able to
do that but this is not something that
is unexpected and I suspect that we'll
see more of it to come in the future the
Russians have got to be very careful
because they're as guilty as others I
don't think they want to have Chechnya
and what they have done and Russia
brought up as part of a countermeasure
but I think Putin is testing these
gambits obviously there's the pressure
of gas in the winter and whether or not
the Russians will leverage that in a
sense they really can't because they
need the money so I think that what
you're seeing here are various gambits
and games to try to exercise leverage
but at the end of the day it's in the
best interest of both East and West for
the Ukraine situation to be resolved as
peaceably as possible but these
conflicts are going to arise tensions
are going to be present some time to
come we just have to realize that this
is going to be the new normal I don't
think that the measures so far that have
imposed by Europe will impress proved
certainly for the short term but for the
long term there needs to be a better
energy policy given that the United
States is going to be producing a great
deal of oil and shale gas there's
opportunity here well I think what
really needs to be done at some stage is
a sit-down between Vladimir Putin and
Barack Obama to work these things out